ON THE ISLANDERS DEFENSE.
PETTERSSON SWINGS AT IT AND
CAN'T KEEP IT IN THE ZONE.
1:20 SHIFT FOR MATT MARTIN.
HE'S ABLE TO GET OFF THE ICE.
>> Keith: IF YOU'RE IN PERIOD
NUMBER TWO, THE ISLANDERS HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THEY SHORTEN UP
THOSE SHIFTS AND MAKE GOOD
PASSES FROM THE EXITS AND THAT
WAS NOT ONE OF THEM.
>> Brendan: DUMOULIN, THE SHOT.
IT GOES IN.
BRIAN DUMOULIN WITH THE SHOT.
CROSBY GETS A PIECE, AND THE
PENGUINS HAVE A LEAD.
>> Keith: WELL, IT'S BEEN ALL
PRESSURE FOR THE ITTSBURGH
PENGUINS IN THIS SECOND PERIOD,
AND THE NEW YORK ISLANDERS NOT
HANDLING IT WELL.
LEDDY TURNING IT OVER, AND
DUMOULIN'S SHOT DIRECTED AND
IT'S A ONE-HANDED TIP BY SIDNEY
CROSBY.
WHAT A PLAY BY THE PENGUINS'
CAPTAIN.
WATCH THE HAND-EYE COORDINATION.
KNOCKS IT DOWN, AND SCORES THE
GOAL.
>> A.J.: INITIALLY IT LOOKED
LIKE GREENE WAS GOING INTO THE
CORNER FOR A PASS, BUT